alter wir nicht
kassel war auch so
über den tag hinweg kommen dass wir das
erste video zwei bands umdrehen keine
ahnung verlangen hier also zu unserem
comeback heißen wir euch sehr herzlich
willkommen
heute testen wir cocktails zügellosen
punktelosen cocktails einfach so dass
asozial zu machen kann so was hat ja
jeder schon mal gesehen hat ist hier so
diese typischen tankstellen dose die man
sich ganz kurz vorm club nummer kauft um
promille hoch zu jagen oder du bist
alkohol ab ende
gedrückt na ja manche von den seen voll
geil ausfindig manche sind jetzt schon
so designt dass ich sagen würde würde
ich an mein stopp drücken die jetzt
vielleicht nicht unbedingt die schnaken
ich lange wir fangen an zu probieren uns
durch anhalt ist also auch ein intro
ganz ehrlich die leute das juk die alle
nicht mehr scheißegal also irgendwie
trinken natürlich weil wir bei kelly
also guckt auch wenn kelly vorbei falls
nicht schon gemacht haben
jetzt das ist ein schönes ding finde ich
es finde ich eigentlich schön aperol
spritz fix und fertig ich mich gut
multiplizieren kennt jeder man trinkt
doch super gerne
aperol spritz das ist dass getränke
herzen obwohl wild berry hat so ein
bisschen ab weil das bei unserem
aktuellen bisschen mehr ab obwohl das
ein bisschen zu bezahlen wenn ich jetzt
werbung für aperol spritz machen müsste
möglichst neben das geld ich sagen wir
mal einheben darauf dass wir uns seit
langer zeit mal wieder sehen einen ganz
ähnlichen ich habe so viele also nur
über kennedy das ist erst mal
präsentieren
das ist unser tolle flasche tolles
design alle ganz toll super toll da muss
man sagen ja sie hat auch eine coole
flaschenform gibt es ab
april sprit hat gekostet 499 höher
drei flaschen preis ist kann ja klar
die edle tropfen
schmeckt nach abpfiff aber da fehlt
irgendwie doch der sekte drin oder
ist der sprint sind ja ich weiß waschen
laut als man es geöffnet hat also ein
bisschen spaß muss sein stimmt er hat
mich nochmal
sechs und zehn hat mich umgehauen und
ist stabil
ich möchte gleich eigentlich mit den
hier beiden staaten
dass die normalen dies auch schon
probiert genau ich bin auch gespannt wie
die schmeckten jetzt macht waren
mischgetränk weist die extrakte
zuckerwatte geschmack ganze mit extra
dirty die uci mango einen mango number
five ist nicht cool oder
das hat doch nichts mit mango zu tun ist
doch candy aber ich hab mal
extra die candy shop verwandelt dann
mund in eine cocktailbar syrien david
projekt einen juicy fantasien ins
kühlregal ja das ja folge
guter sound er ist wichtig bei diesen
schier spears in mainz riecht sehr wohl
nochmal ein sie sich ja doch noch kehren
die
[Musik]
probieren nur positives kann ich will
nämlich ein kühlschrank umsonst von mir
bekommt und er wäre nie so release-party
[Gelächter]
schmeckt ein bisschen wie diese
ausbessern das finde ich klasse
das schmeckt mir richtig lecker
[Gelächter]
das ist richtig lecker für einen
wirklich guten preis
50 es geht ja das jetzt halt bis ins
netz hat einen klassischen einsteiger an
darauf sollten wir das auch richtig
eklig es bringen was er glauben was
richtig eklig ist das und das von goce
die täglichen brüder
die zwei dem club kommen
ich glaube gegen
das löst in mir den magen krampft aus so
wartet hier kriegt ihr dem wunderbar nur
verdeckt gefälligst eingesetzt ja und
das ist sex und das war nicht aber cool
weil das ja auch wirklich ja man kann ja
zu sagen okay fruchtwein mich gedrängt
ist jetzt vielleicht nicht klüger
cocktail und gehört nicht in die
kategorie aber sie haben sex on the
beach das ist wirklich stimmt wir haben
eigentlich und aperol ist auch eher so
ein longdrink mäßig
richtige cocktails am 1 das ist alles
was
ich dabei lag
ja also das schmeckt nicht so gut aber
es schmeckt zu künstlich finde ich klärt
das ist nicht gut
ja ein bisschen wie sohn bitter lemon
tja das mini ein alkoholisches getränk
mit titeln wie sex on the beach schmeckt
ein bisschen
chemische labor balco
labor tores
das wollte ich genau so sagen was hat es
denn gekostet 250 601 das hier kann man
machen die unvergessenen david nummer zu
geben was für eine bewertung also ich
würd bei ihr sagen david korrekt und
ehrlich
mango
nicht lecker handyshop 670 gibt mango
und neun von zehn und kennen die schon
7 7
aus dem hause bacardi haben wir ein
bacardi rum cola und einmal bacardi
oder der dose verstecken das geht sogar
für gut
situierte
ein krasses design die dosen sind
richtig schön asian ist das sind
wirklich sehr arm yahoo ökologie damals
wieder in klassischen cocktails oder ist
halt übernehmen wie sehr das profil das
gesicht gespritzt
lecker
schmeckt die cola schweifen die cola
schmeckt wieso die kinder wie so ein
colonia wirklich acht von zehn gehen
neben motto acht von zehn dem onkel 33
kerzen da kann man darunter würden 279
sind stolzer preise gut aber das ist ja
auch keinen dass er auch richtiger
alkohol oder nicht so kinder alkohol
nichts gegen
na ja gut aber zählt man das in den
preis dazu das ist doppelt soviele
prozente wir sind hier weil wir jetzt
auch so rum und collagen hat das ist ja
gar nicht um das bisher als nächstes
haben wir selzer und selbst kenne ich
aus amerika also hart cells
international flavors
vita masters
weil ja genau guck mal das hat 4,5
prozent alkohol das heißt es kann ja nur
auch weine ab aktiv oder sowas der
gärung alkohol aus fermentierten zucker
keinen destination goalie bei rum oder
wodka
angebot war es 150 oder
also wenn sie so schmeckt so shears im
fax ist recht so gut
das hat doch eingeholt und mein gottes
mclean wasser mit mango geschmack dieser
mango geschmack schmeckt wie eine echte
man wohl aber für ihn war es halt so
will irgendwo anders ist als dr voc
mango wer frische lasse mich doch nicht
vor aber wenn ich doch nicht nach
schmecken dafür alkohol ist das ist dann
der silbermarkt ja dann nur besoffen
werden ist ja dann nur da sind perfekt
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht warum du das nicht kennst
das lecker aber ich sehe das immer auf
welchen titels habe ich selber zur
abgabe der kirche geschmeckt mir richtig
gut er kommt ja so im nachgeschmack und
der mango geschmack hätte dich so
richtig in die kasse des trends ideen
hat nur von minus kalorien das ist nur
ein film
marketing ist marica es ist der
geschmack ich weiß es nicht das ist aber
doch das sollte durch verboten gehören
also sorry das ist meine ich jetzt mal
14 bin das ist mein einstiegs alkohol
hätte der würde dann merken dass alkohol
trinkt was für eine bewertung 10 14 ist
ganz ein
als nächstes gibt es bei buch und batida
de coco also beides sehr lustlos haltige
da ist ein papagei drauf das war eine
signalisieren tropische hitze und
kohlensäure mal liebe mitchristen jugend
und das wahrscheinlich nicht
bestimmen und hier sind 250 kalorien
sind und beim harzer hast du nur 94
malibu
239 ok und 1 250 also muss 1 30 cent
besser schmecken als meist sehr gut
ich liebe es doch mal getränk mainz ist
dass praktiker jetzt nicht manchmal
bakula aber das ist geschmackssache
ich habe an sich ist ein heftiges
getränk auf 41 recht voll wie solero wie
das eis mit sahne und orange außenrum ja
ja ja stimmen stimmt schmeckt auch so
habe auch irgendwie kacke
dem malibu würde ich sagen
von 10
5 als nächstes haben wir eine bowle mit
erdbeergeschmack und hugo spritztour
gespritzt oder 90 cent
mainz kostet 2000 euro bei mir ist mehr
drin oder
300 oder aus furcht war
klinkrad also wenn das jetzt gut
schmeckt und nur 1 euro kostet
völlig besorgt
dort platz finden
wenn er bundeskanzler
das riecht nach in ferber hast du schon
mal die haare entfernt ja hab ich das so
klingt als es selbst das geht gar nicht
- 10 15
20 vor dem kauf das nicht mag auf das
wirklich nicht dass es nächstes haben
wir von bombay den gin tonic und von
petru den caipirinha das ist eigentlich
pedro für eine marke die machen diesen
kattaka ich weiß nicht wie man es genau
ausspricht und das ist diese cholera in
katerini reinkommen findest du das nicht
komisch dass sein spruch drauf ist ja
manchmal schon
kennt jeder also kann es gut sein und
bombay ist eigentlich auch eine gute mal
so beliebte marke
ist doch ein bisschen
ich auch genau so stelle ich mir nämlich
vor wie dosen alkohol schmeckt
[Musik]
hast du diese adels personen queen
irgendwas dass sie auf dem bombay
geklatscht worden ist und er los geht's
das schmeckt wirklich wie ein fisch
erwiesen schritte weiter drückt kann ich
meine dieser gin tonic hatten schon
panik aber das weiß eben doch nix
wirklich gut der journey ist okay ich
glaube wir sind einfach nur raten fans
ihre tonne
bei alkohol es stimmt zeit wirklich
unser geld durch ein für alkohol aus
gibt es umso meistens wenn möglich
bisschen damit beschäftigt qualitativer
ist alkohol schmeckt auch besser
willkommen zum großen
finale jetzt schon ich fühl mich das so
klar
[Musik]
also wir kennen penny parkplatz neue
getrennt sondern freuen uns mit auf eis
und jack denn jetzt reicht es immer noch
1 habe ich oft getrunken als teenager
ein als wir oder als ich in der 10
klasse war mir eine auf abschlussfahrt
waren haben wir in holland da sind wir
diese supermärkte reihe laufen weil es
dort so was wie es will noch eis gab als
er in deutschland verboten war echt es
war so also sowie heißen alkopops
alkopops
wanderfreudige von den skandal mit
alcopops in den news die ganze zeit dass
wir jetzt ein teenager von
abgraben gekürzt anderen abgekauft
deshalb preislich liegen wir hier du
hast 250 bis man auf 1 ja
schon vielen drei euro entdeckt denn es
macht ja wohl auch kreissieger da haben
wir uns ein richtiges bild ein typ der
pitbull hat oder irgendwie so einen
gefährlichen kampf und
schild dann irgendwie so ein bisschen am
pumpt man dann tritt er sich abends mit
seinem freund und dann sitzen die alle
über zum couch herum und dann ist so
eine und dann brauchen die so am
couchtisch also jemanden der zahnlos ist
euro da hatte doch keiner die figur
nicht schmeckt vielleicht kann man beim
besten willen ich glaube ich auch gerne
überzeugen aber wenn ich an jackie cola
aus der dose denkt wenn menschlich
einfach nur das kam scheiße war
deine vermutung hat sich bestätigt nach
ist so schlosses man auf eis
aber das ist ja ist nicht gut aber okay
ist ein teenager getränke ich weiß was
ich meine ja es ist toll und wenn du
trainer bist wirst du dieses getränk
mögen über natürlich über 18 teenager
klar 1920 so ich habe es mit 14
getrunken aber muss nicht wieder machen
aber kelly ist auch kein gutes vorbild
irans man darf also das ist
oder die harten kommen in den garten
jack daniel's tennessee usa
aber ich nach division harte typen karl
ist es schmeckt nicht ganz mein
geschmack würden
die harten glück wenn jetzt 13 12 6 so
kelly wer es denn jetzt unser gewinner
des abends lasst uns alle mal
den
mit vorsichtig im alkohol und so kennt
euro abonniert uns ist dieses video
schauen jetzt mal kellys video und da
hat mir auch jetzt das hier zu gucken
lieber aktiv hier werde etwas merkt so
ein kleiner heimlicher favorit nach oben
geschafft hat ist der bacardi tag
danke